congratulations you just did a lot of
stuff let's do a recap you've wrote your
first lines of code and deployed it to
App Engine
you got conference central up and
running and you've tried out the API
Explorer don't underestimate the API
Explorer it's a great tool to use to try
out API and it's not limited to your own
API so you can use it for any Google API
so all good stuff but let's now talk
about user authentication
many applications require that a user is
registered and signed in before using
the application we will also require
this for conference central so let's
look at how we do that it used to be the
case that almost every application had
to create their own user management
system that would mean that you would
have to write all the code from scratch
in order for your users to use your
applications well good for us that is
not needed anymore
with App Engine you can use third-party
authentication with Cloud endpoints such
as Google+ sign-in but also other ones
can be used in conference central we
will require a Google account for
sign-in so how do we know that the user
is signed into their Google account when
they use conference central that is
actually taken care of by Cloud
endpoints a Cloud endpoints API method
can optionally take a user object as its
first argument and if the user object is
not null then the user is signed in but
if it's now then we throw an exception
which the client should receive and
redirect for sign-in could it be more
easy
hmm you might say now but what about
security and privacy
well that is still taken care of by
Google sign-in or the third party
authentication provider so this
mechanism is the best of two worlds
combined a simple way to add user
authentication to your app combined with
the strong security and privacy
standards of Google alright that's
enough talking time for you to do some
coding again by adding user
authentication to your conference
central good luck